let's go back to uh what i brought up
earlier when you said uh snipers have a
god complex so can you unpack that what
do you mean when you say snipers have a
god complex
whenever we
at the behavioral analysis unit look at
a crime at a series of crimes we reverse
engineer back to the type of person who
committed that crime so
basically
in the case of snipers the choice the
weapon choice
is one of distance
the whole point is that there is no
physical connection between the offender
and the victim in a sniper case and the
sniper chooses to take life from above
and afar and that's very godlike
whereas there are other offenders who
want to get up close and personal manual
strangulation
stabbing those things are are sort of in
your face and
that it requires a different type of
personality and generally people choose
to snipe versus
actually one-on-one contact with their
victims
because they feel
they want to feel omnipotent they want
to feel powerful and in this case so so
for example if if you look at the dc
sniper case
one of the major issues in that case was
that
there was a dichotomy between how
this person
planned and executed shootings
flawlessly
and how
they communicated to us
through written
the written word
and
jim fitzgerald who was sitting next to
me in the in the bau
said everybody was talking about in this
sniper case how this guy
six times within 27 hours one shot one
kill he was in and out he there was no
decompensation there was no adrenaline
rush that made him make mistakes he was
a ghost
and
everybody said he's got to be
older
settled
police or military trained and have
police or military experience because
it's not as easy to pull the trigger on
human beings as it is on paper targets
and so everybody was agreeing to that
but then jim fitzgerald said yeah but if
you look at this tarot card
and this letter
that they left us
it says this is for you mr police
and that told fitzgerald that that the
writer was looking up to the police
not like from a powerful position
omnipotent position but from below
and he
mr police is is a common phrase in
in reggae songs in the caribbean and so
he felt there was a caribbean influence
here and that the person was younger and
even one of the one of the
communications had those little stars
that you put on a kindergartener's paper
or picture
like what the hell what kind of a
sophisticated 45 year old is gonna put
that on a communication to the cops so
fitz says
if he's an adult he's barely an adult
but he's more likely 15 or 16
and everybody just blew up at that and i
said
look then
either
this guy is incredibly poised and
sophisticated when he plans and executes
his shootings
but he decompensates when he's
communicating to us or for the first
time in us history we have a sniper team
and the rest of the people say what are
you crazy snipers have a god complex
they don't work well together they've
never done it in the history of u.s
crime
why would this happen now and i said
well you could do it if one of them's 45
and one of them's 15
and this one is controlling that one the
younger one
and
if he's controlling him completely he
may be sexually victimizing him to do
that
and everybody said well you're an expert
in that field so that's why you know
you've got to hammer everything looks
like you nailed to you you're just
superimposing that well it turned out
about 10 or 11 years later malvo came
out and said
almost from day one that muhammad had
been sexually victimizing him so if you
like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]